Against the leader of the movement for the of Cameroon,
maurice camto.
Truth or lie the question arises And to answer this question,
and that our television has just proceeded by fact checking and discovering
a reality of the case where it accuses maurice camto of having initiated the
constitutional revision of two thousand and eight on the non-limitation of
mandates and the elaboration of the electoral code of two thousand and twelve.
The editorial bears the signature of Guizzo.
Following the vituberation of ariette flowed at the place of maurice camto.
Regarding the constitutional revision of two thousand eight and the adoption
of the current electoral code in two thousand twelve,
we proceeded to some verifications We went to
the archives of the national assembly,
where are kept the minutes of debate,
yet on the constitutional revision in two thousand eight and the adoption of
the electoral code in two thousand eight on the constitutional
revision in two thousand eight,
the archives of the national assembly indicate that this revision took place
during the March session and that bill number
eight hundred and nine bar bjl bar a.
N,
amending and supplementing certain provisions of the law number ninety-six
bar zero-six of January mille-neuf-cent-quatre-vingt-seize the constitution
of June 2 mille-neuf-cent-soixante-douze and was defended by the minister
of territorial administration and decentralization at the time,
marafa abidu yaya aryatecco's assertion that it was the minister of justice
amadou ali and his minister delegate maurice campo,
who defended.
This bill is therefore.
In addition,
with regard to the Electro Adopter course in two thousand and twelve The minutes
of the debate in the national assembly point out that the law number two thousand
and twelve bar zero zero one was adopted during the March session Two thousand
and twelve was defended by the minister of territorial mutation
and decentralization of the time,
rené emmanuel sadi Once again,
by the name of maurice campo,
henriette and coué tangle the brushes.
Since the president of Le Merci had not been
a member of the government since November.
Two thousand and eleven .
..
The reasons for the flight of green wood are then amply measured.
For I am shaken henriette.
After his attacks against maurice campo
Immigration.